so we have here Paul Ivanov and Thomas
clover of ipython ipython
of a sort of being the cool kid in the
room I was looking on github risa you
guys have like three thousand six
hundred stars that roughly correct now
so can you name any product any project
that has more stars in python django
form of me Jang baby Django things I
looked pandas pandas is very close
spinners had about 3,000 yeah Butler
talked to today about the back end or
about the the protocols in backend of
ipython when did the new system count
was at 07 08 the sort of the same system
I think 20 2011 oh the the protocol
system with the separation between front
ends and kernels was out of 11 okay and
that was in about twenty eleven but guys
and since then we've seen a number of
products come out yeah I about the
notebook is very very popular but uh
sort of magic behind the magic and I
guess we're learning about that today so
let's welcome Paul and Thomas thank you
thank you Matt so I'm Paulie one off
Thomas I are both at UC Berkeley or both
core I Python developers and we want to
tell you a little bit about the ipython
protocol if you want the resources like
the this is an eye Python notebook that
I'm running and that's at this URL down
here I python / front to back and I just
wanted to show you that this is a live
notebook so this is dangerous right
we're gonna we are going to do some live
coding alright so the first thing about
this talk is that we are talking
together but I'm gonna go first and then
Thomas is going to go after me and but
it's one talk and and for those for
those of you that know both Thomas and I
you have to probably say that I'm the
bigger ass but I'm going first so so
that's that so what is ipython I guess
at PI data it's been said you don't need
to introduce what I python is but I just
wanted to put up on into a little cloud
what all the sort of pieces of ipython
and the reason that I want to do that is
I want to sort of outline what the
things that we will talk about what the
things we won't talk about right so and
but before
that sort of what the punchline of the
talk is so this is your one chance to
tune in and get something from the stock
it's that if you implement any one of
these pieces you get access to the other
pieces for free right so that's the big
deal is that we've decoupled things so
that you can only work on the piece that
you really care about and get the
benefits of the other things in in the
ipython project so and it's all bsd
license so this talk all the stuff
that's in that blue cloud is out of
scope the notebook is only sort of half
covered right we're going to talk about
the colonel and we're going to talk
Thomas is going to talk about the
colonel and kernels that should have
been plural and then I'll talk about the
front ends okay so there's an analogy
here it's imperfect but it's useful and
that's the analogy of the web so on the
web you have a web browser on the left
and it speaks HTTP to a web server right
so that's a sort of pretty standard on
the ipython we have slightly different
language it's a client-server
relationship to berners-lee kept the
server change the client name to browser
we kept the client name change the
server name to Colonel and the way the
client and the colonel talk to each
other is what I'm going to call ICCP for
the purposes of us for the verses of
this talk what's ICCP well it's the
interactive computing communications
protocol I wanted the ipython protocol
IP was taken I don't that usually gets a
bigger laugh it's the first time I'm
giving this talk but that usually gets a
bigger laugh interactive computing
protocol ICP was also taken by some
clowns and the internet Akash protocol
okay so I CCP is what I'm going to call
it okay so we have different pieces here
you have the kernel which is the
computational engine right that's the
server part it accepts messages it
performs actions on behalf of the user
of the client and then it sends the
results back out okay and there's a
one-to-many relationship between kernel
and clients so Carl can't have multiple
clients just like a web server can
be serving multiple web browsers at a
given time and so so you could have a
regular console connection a cutie
console of my Python another of my
Python and a by Python can all connected
to this kernel right here and the space
between them is left blank for the
purposes of just saying that there is a
messaging protocol here and we're not
going to cover it in detail but just
sort of give you enough of the flavor to
make you feel comfortable that this is
something that should you want to you
can actually go home and read up on a
little bit and implement pretty quickly
and then get the benefit of the rest of
the ecosystem ok so the messages that
are exchanged back and forth is consist
of a header which has a message ID a
message type a reference as a parent
header if it's a reply to something and
then it has content where the content
sort of depends on what the message type
is so an execute request might have the
code that you want to send right as a
client you make an executor request and
then the colonel may review an executed
reply that may be say ok I did that and
here the things that you wanted or give
you an error and saying here's your
trace back here's where the problem is
ok so this isn't all there is to it but
these are sort of the main core parts of
it ok the client connects exactly one
kernel that's that's the way we have
right now it sends messages to Colonel
on user actions and its job is to
display the colonel messages when it's
appropriate so it turns out that the
client will receive all messages that
the colonel sends it but the clients
that we ship in ipython right now only
hang on to and and display the messages
that they generated that were replies to
their actions so there may be other
messages that they're hearing but
they're just sort of letting them drop
they're letting them fall on the ground
they don't care right that doesn't have
to be that way but that's just the way
it is right now and for example in vim
ipython and by Python I don't do that I
capture all messages I display all
messages to the user because it's
of that may be what you want I may be
useful why would you want to have many
clients well you have differences in for
example the first client that we had is
the Qt console that's the first are the
first separation and what we got with
that is the ability to edit like us in a
sane manner multi-line input right we
weren't we weren't slaved to read line
anymore and you could actually have in a
cutie environment you have rich syntax
highlighting rate right away and you
could have multi line editing you can
also display images it turns out in Fiji
console so display capabilities in the
Qt console are better than they are in
the terminal and in the notebook they're
even better right because you can embed
video you can embed JavaScript you guys
know this stuff another reason is that
there's a difference in persistence so
you could you can't save and rerun parts
of the console and the Qt console code
that you've written and executed that's
not the case if you use the notebook
because everything that you've wanted to
save you saved in the IP ynb file it's
also not the say not true in vim ipython
because you were just working in a
Python file and sending code and getting
the results back in line and so you
could use the work that you did is
actually saved also you may have have a
preference for a command-line interface
so I have a chronic CLI problem it's
terminal and then you have you may have
different client side requirements so
the Python is required if you want to
use the things that we ship out of the
box except for the notebook the notebook
requires a modern browser that may not
be something that fits in your
environment and you still want to use
the ipython machinery so you may need to
write your own client that is on the JVM
or that is on some other platform okay
so clients that ship with ipython is the
Qt console and the ipython console and
when you launch those either of those
two commands you're actually launching
two things you're launching the colonel
and the client at the same time if you
want to launch just the client to
connect to a kernel that is already
existing for example maybe a notebook
started up a kernel for you you could
just pass the existing flag and then
that won't start a new kernel and you
can just connect to a kernel it's
already there ok so the third party ones
that I'm going to talk about arvind my
python and by python how am i doing on
time I didn't you go ok we're good ok so
so then my Python was a plug-in that i
wrote for them with min reagan Kelly's
help at sify 2011 Sprint's we can do a
live demo and I here I outlined a little
public service announcement for Mac
users ok so i really like this quote i
have randomly generated quotes when i
log into a shell and i found this one so
that you guys could all read it that's
Donald Knuth ok so how does vmi Python
work well I have over here this is a
live notebook so let's let's prove to
you that it's live and saying x equals
hi pie ooh data live coding all right
what is the value of x ok it's hype I
data and that it's really ipython let's
say that y is equal to let's run a shell
command date ok so what is why ok it's
Saturday May third this is one we give
him the talk good i'm going to switch
over here and i'm going to start up vim
and just a random python file it's empty
there's nothing here right now and i'm
just going to launch a vim command
ipython ok so that's a command that i
provide and vim ipython what this gets
me is the ability to now say oh live
demos all right if i say print hello
here
oh come on print hello all right there
we go good okay so I've just sent that
over and so what is X can I get the
results from x if I do X here x is hype
I data why is Saturday that I can also
get text completion a tab completion
rather so you don't use a tab in vim for
that sort of thing but here are the
things that X can do X with a string and
so maybe I forgot how does how does find
work well what if I do double ? that
gets me the doc string so I'm still in
vim but i'm getting the the output of
that I Python sends along the
introspection stuff for free okay and on
the carnal that was already open so
that's that's been my Python all right
next is by Python my python is a new
project that I've worked about two and a
half maybe three days on a month ago so
it's it's actually it's month-aversary
was yesterday um so so let's three
cheers for by python by Python let's do
the live demo for that so let me quit
out of here I don't care to save so well
by Python gets you is that it uses this
you'll notice it took up the whole
screen okay so it actually uses her wid
so if I as i start typing i don't have
to type tab it actually gives me
completions right away so if i import
this and if i do this dot here are the
things that this can do and as I tab
through them unlike in a new read line
it'll just give me the options right and
you have to type a matter explicitly
here I can tab through them and and see
the doc string for it ok and then
moreover if I if I execute something
over here like print I'm running out of
time sorry Thomas
if I do that here I have to press a key
it doesn't there's no event loop here I
have to press a key but as soon as i do
then it prints out the thing that went
over the wire over the protocol and we
got it back okay so that's that embed is
your friend here so there's a ipython
hat you can import ipython and do call
ipython embed in any of your Python code
to get an interactive Python prompt a
single single console in the single good
old classic ipython that you get if you
just type and I Python if you type in
embed under colonel that will get you
print you a string like this and i'm not
going to demo it here because so the
thomas has enough time to do his demos
but basically it allows you to use any
of the clients that I just covered to
hook into your python process wherever
it is that you made that embed so think
of in bed as being a set trace but on
steroids right or I don't know I don't
know what's more than steroids but it's
sort of on steroids and Red Bull and
whatever else you want to throw at it
okay so the takeaway from clients is
that your favorite tool can talk
bidirectionally to python that's the
takeaway from that and I'll let Thomas
take over he's number one as Paul says
I'm number one and so it pulls very
neatly handed over with half of our time
leaving time for questions so I'm going
to talk about the other half of the
equation which is the backends so this
protocol this protocol system and the
decoupling of backends and front ends
was originally designed so that we could
have multiple different different
interfaces that you were using to talk
to the same code and it we've we've got
several of those as Paul showed it
quickly became apparent that in a sense
what was even more useful with this was
the ability to write different backends
and the protocol is all specified in 0
and Q and Jason which language
independent things it's not like it
doesn't use pythons pickle or anything
and there's nothing well there are a few
Python specific bits in it at the moment
which were
kind of weeding out and but it's it's
perfectly possible to kind of work
around those and implement the protocol
for other languages so one of the first
communities to do this seriously was the
Julia community and julia is a very new
upcoming language for scientific
computing and it has optional type
annotations that let it compile code for
better better performance and and they
were they had plans to write a a
notebook interface similar to I hyphen
and when they realized that you could
just implement kernel for ipython they
decided that they do that and make
ipython in its I Julia flavor there
their main interface and so I can switch
over to I've actually set up all of
these systems on my laptop for the demo
so this is an I Python notebook running
in running Julia code so you can see
this is the very first time executing
with no imports and it already knows
about sine functions you can see there's
Julia's syntax for four loops and things
syntax highlighting doesn't seem to be
working here I'm not quite sure why that
is but they also they implement the same
so that this is something they have to
implement independently these out in and
out our something that are implemented
in the colonel they've taken the same
notion so you can do out bracket square
brackets to is the result from the
second executed cell and they've got
some some nice functionality for working
with matrices and it doesn't doesn't
look so good on the screw the small
resolution but you can see there they've
got this nice they've integrated nicely
with the display machinery so you can do
nice Unicode display and things the
little dots breaking up the matrix
Unicode things
and they've also implemented the tab
completion so i can press tab there to
get the list of different options and if
i press shift tab the introspection
thing and that's our bug not there as
the fact that that tooltip has flown off
to bottom the screen but if i created
again and so julia has julia has
multiple overloaded implementations of
the same function depending on what you
pass to it so that's what they show and
you try to inspect something all the
different things that you could pass
into it and so this is the julia is very
much the the most mature and best
developed colonel other than the ipython
kernel that we maintain ourselves and
they also have integration another kind
of integration with python which is they
they have a way of wrapping Python
libraries into Julia so this is using
their pie call package and it's actually
loaded the Python cyhi da to optimize
method and it's even it's passing the
julia julia equivalent of a lambda into
a Python function and that's all working
perfectly and and pipe lot is a wrapper
around matplotlib to run it with julia
julia native syntax so it takes it takes
a few seconds but as our that's a map
hot lead plot generated and highly from
julia code and you can see it says pi
object matplotlib i don't know and as
that as that display as the display of
that plot probably hints they've also
implemented all of the and multimedia
display so this is this line of code is
partly hidden due to an opera power bugs
but have
you can see that we're just displaying
raw text as HTML there and you can do
clever or integration with Julia we've
defined a function which defined a type
which knows how to display itself us
HTML so yeah that was Julia so then a
few weeks ago I was invited to go and
take part in a hackathon at our open
sigh and I just found out today that
they actually put a picture from the
hack phone on the website and that would
be me sitting in the background so
thankfully I was wearing a clean shirt
that day and so after a couple of days I
had a working implementation of an hour
colonel so you can have this is another
ipython notebook talking to a different
kernel now it's running our code and
again this looks slightly nicer on a
larger screen size and and again has the
implementation of the of plotting this
time it's using our native plots and
that's saved to a PNG and then sent to
the netbook front end so you can get
your plots in line as you want and
there's a separate I made a separate
package I odd I our display and which
deals handles the rich display functions
and the idea of that is that we've also
got a our cell magic inside the ipython
colonel so that you can mix Python code
and our code and we wanted it to be
possible to use the same display
mechanism whether you're in the native
our kernel or in the ipython our cell
magic and and that will be possible the
part of the the part of the our magic
that would integrate with that isn't
implemented yet but I plan to get to
that
and and straight away within a few days
of of the hackathon where where I
implemented this ramnath I won't try to
pronounce his last name I was up half
thorne and very enthusiastic about this
so he straightaway started using it and
with his our Maps library so that's just
defining a bit of boilerplate and then
we can display and this is using HTML to
display a JavaScript map things this is
really interactive in the notebook and
that integrates with our computations so
we're providing some way points in an
hour list here and when we add that
information to the map the JavaScript
can pick a route between them and so
that's that's a relatively new thing was
already starting to see keen use and
just to demonstrate that I'm you know
this isn't those are kind of good
examples of using this in a scientific
computing context which is really kind
of the space we're aiming for and but
it's not it's not anyway limited to
languages that follow a particular
paradigm so a scale if you've not used
it as a functional language that uses a
very very different paradigm in a very
different syntax from Python or r or
Julia and these simple things will look
much the same the first one always takes
a little while but we're rapidly getting
into things the highway pretend I
understand but look it's clever Haskell
stuff
yeah I didn't actually write that what's
going on so but seems quite accurate and
it can it's doing some rich output there
it also integrates with our little what
we call the page which is the panel that
pops up at the bottom here to display
help and yeah that's demonstrating that
output output comes in live as you're
running the computation it doesn't all
wait until the end and here's the rich
display machinery hopefully yes so you
can this is using HTML to display
objects in different ways and again I
don't claim to understand how the house
colors doing that but it is there's more
different display things including so
there's some custom stuff in the front
end that I have scale ads and so things
that it doesn't know how to display come
up with this button and you click it and
it shows you what the error was when it
tried to display it it also integrates
with a haskell static analysis tool so
that it will complain about you've done
your code like this you could do it like
this and I imagine this way to turn that
off if it gets annoying there's another
integration this is the haskell
equivalent of docstrings so this is this
is probably the third most
well-developed colonel after Python and
Julia this is sharing different methods
and
so then a couple more things I just want
to quickly show so on my demos so I've
demonstrated three of the kernels and
you've of course seen the Python kernel
which is what you're normally running
when you run a Python and we have
Colonels in some level of development in
all of these languages that may be
pretty basic I i wrote the go colonel to
try and learn go and i wouldn't
recommend anyone uses it because it
doesn't work very well and don't go
using it thanks full of there's a
fascinating mom called calico which runs
on who gets the dotnet virtual machine
and lets you like switch between
different languages and is doing all
sorts of crazy things there's a scholar
back-end from a camel back end F sharp
Erlang and yeah and that's just you know
most of these we have most of these the
ipython team is not involved in we've
just you know I worked on go and our
mins helped with the Ruby colonel but
most of them are people who've just ran
our docs may be asked us a few questions
and gone away and implemented it
themselves so we think that's really
good testament to how well this protocol
works and we're talking to all of those
communities in designing new versions of
the protocol and the notebook format and
everything say I should have said that
one of the things you get for free when
you implement kernel is that that's like
the code execution is completely
separate from all the notebook saving
and loading stuff so you get all of our
machinery to store the code and the
notes and the results of that in the
notebook without having to do anything
else and and a quick sneak preview of
for ipython 3.0 so at the moment you
have to like to use the notebook with an
R colonel you have to give it this long
command line ipython notebook Colonel
manager come come on
equals and then a list of arguments to
pass to start in our kernel and I
python3 there's going to be a way for
kernels to kind of register themselves
so there's a bíblia directory with a
list of kernels and I Python will
introspect that so when you create a new
notebook you'll be able to just click on
a drop down and say this notebook is
going to be running our code or Julia
code or Haskell code or any of the other
languages and this is you know this is
the little spec file that the our kernel
will install something like this on your
system and this tells ipython to start
our and call this function and this is
already sufficiently implemented that in
ipython in the development version of a
Python now you can start the console not
the notebook yet but the console or the
Qt console with this dash dash Colonel
Flagg and I've got the IR file installed
on my system so I can yes works good and
ok text it doesn't work yes nevermind I
can quit like that and and I can even
you'll also be able to go between so
this is now going to be the front end
running in Python 2 so you can see it
says I some to up at the top there but
if I princess top version that's Python
3 so that will that's a brief sneak
preview of what will be coming in the
next version of ipython this integration
so that it knows about different types
of kernel and that's the end of what
I've got to talk about so that's just
the right time to open it up for
questions
hi first of all I'm a big fan of ipython
and I advocated often and vigorously to
people when I meet them I thank thank
you for so much for this work so I'm a
little dismayed at this trend of trying
to throw every ever more complex
JavaScript library into a cell in
ipython is there some way that you could
manage expectations or put a damper on
that or something because it it's all
very useful in everything but I think
that it's diverting precious attention
to what's already amazing and great you
know I mean I'm not quite sure what you
mean by probably person was more of a
comment right I'm not quite sure what
you mean by showing every JavaScript
library into the cell I mean there's
there's quite a lot of JavaScript
libraries that we depend on and I don't
think we're particular time to reduce
those user code can obviously display
stuff using d3 and whatever other
libraries at once and I yeah I'm not
whether that's a problem I think it's
more it's also more of a usage issue
it's it's sort of how people we make a
tool and how people choose to use that
tool or or you know add on to that tool
we sort of that steps up to the
community rate so like what your comment
on is people are finding themselves
grabbing Rafael and grabbing all these
different different libraries d3 and
different things and and for some things
that things will stabilize like MPL d3
will be maybe one of the solutions or
Vincent or something like that they're
just gonna it's we're in this exciting
period where there's an embarrassment of
riches and in the sort of things that we
can do and it's not clear what are the
right things to do so we're just going
to just let entropy figure it out and
just just and turn up the heat right
just that's what that's what we can do
that's what you can do so I'm curious
with all the all these other languages
developing kind of front ends using the
ipython architecture is are you seeing
any fragmentation where you get you know
three different attempts to make an our
notebook and then people are having to
figure out which one they should be
using not so far and so far I'm not
aware of any language but because there
is a one other colonel written in Python
which is a is called simple kernel and
that's purely as an example for people
wanting to write other kernels other
than that I'm not aware of any any
languages where more than one person has
tried to implement a colonel and we
maintain a list on our wiki of the
different kernels that are available so
there's an easy place to go to see if
somebody's already written it for your
language but Krista for example I was
the case in for the Haskell colonel the
Haskell kernel that we would that Thomas
demonstrated is actually a reimplement
ation of a haskell kernel that somebody
else through together and then sort of
left hanging and didn't quite finish
didn't quite fit all the right parts and
someone else came along and and picked
it up and could start a new project
altogether and so so there is some
fragmentation but again it's one of
those things that the ones that last the
ones that people really put time in
those are the ones that tend to stick if
there's no oh yeah here we go
is the documentation on how to integrate
new Colonel's life on the ipython
website and then the second thing is the
BI python that you showed is
particularly the just scrolling through
the dogs dog strings part of it is
pretty interesting is that is there a
plan for that to come into ipython it's
all right point how you want to take the
first part of it yes so in terms of
creating new kernels the useful starting
points are this is so this is on the
ipython wiki the page called projects
using ipython it has the list of kernels
so there's a blog post by the creator of
the I Haskell kernel which a lot of
people have found useful and the simple
colonel by the author of the Calico
project is a very useful example and
this document is the ipython messaging
spec so this tells you like all the all
the different bits of Jason that are
passed back and forth that's a really
valuable document and it includes the
top you know details of the messaging
pattern and the the wire format that the
messages are serialized into as for the
stuff for the second part of the
question so the by Python sort of
tabbing through completions and getting
the the doc string it's definitely
something that's doable I'd like I'd
like it at the dope book but I have to
you know we have to work with with other
developers and what they think you know
it's it's not it's not my product I mean
the reason that I was able to do that in
by python is because I wrote it so I get
to decide I get to make decisions on it
I don't get to make decisions on ipython
you know single unilaterally right so we
have to eat something we have to hash
out and and i'm looking to brian because
because Brian's big big brains behind a
lot of this stuff so it's it's something
that we it's it's possible and it's
definitely possible as an extension
we've
especially a night Python 2 point 0 a
lot of things that where you can decide
what the different key bindings do and
so maybe you'll weaponize your your tab
key differently then is in the in the
built-in that comes shipped out of the
box yeah one of the things we keep
trying to emphasize is like there's a
million a month things that would be
really awesome if we just did X and
we're desperately trying to encourage
people can do a hex going to X without
us you can we come we can't integrate
everything under the Sun so we're trying
to add lots of like extension points and
you know these mechanisms for different
kernels and famous and that includes in
the front ends alright so oh there's
another one how do you tell what version
by Python you're running you go I pipe
oh here there's my demo you go import
ipython I Python ipython dot sis version
sis what sews info sorry sis version
sorry oh if you rent if you don't
customize your prompt you just type
ipython and it tells you oh yeah that's
right that's right well are you who but
who does that who does that I want to
switch back not not to have a switching
back battle but so that's that's Thomas
would refer and that's my prompt when i
launched ipython um but I wanted to show
you because I have we have two more
minutes thank you for your questions
something that i just spent more time on
so this is like double diamond territory
so so feel free to tune out it's sort of
you know you know this isn't a bunny
slope but to extend the analogy for for
you know I CCP and HTTP you can think of
the notebook server is actually the
ipython notebook server is actually you
can think of it as kind of a proxy where
between your web browser on the
javascript in your web browser and the
notebook server we speak I CCP over
WebSockets ok and then on our behalf on
the client's behalf the notebook server
instantiates a colonel and
speaks to it using zeromq now that also
means and some of you may already take
advantage of this possibility you can
get a direct route to that Colonel using
any of the other clients that's not the
notebook client right and so I just drew
a little sort of sequence diagram of the
sort of thing that happens is that the
notebook server first initiates the
colonel starts it up and sends you the
ipython notebook filed JSON file that
you requested the javascript in your
browser interprets it then the user
types in x equals one presses shift
enter or control enter that sends an
execute request and the in prompt goes
to star saw allocate tons from x equals
100 that's right yeah so there's a bug
in here i wrote this very late last
night it becomes 42 it's the meaning of
life execute 42 goes then to the colonel
the colonel does its thing to do execute
42 that's a valid Python statement so it
says okay and the execute count was one
this is the first statement that you ran
so that it'll say in the message execute
count 1 execute count 1 & okay messages
sent back to your JavaScript that's
running in your browser and then your
browser updates your impromptu Bo this
was one in one and there was no out
because X is x equals 42 or one
depending on which one you take is just
an assignment opera operation so there's
no out one for that and with that oh
look at that on the dot so I don't have
a quick question oh so you ruined that
you're ruining the xiii can control the
clock oh that's right he's got in two
minutes two minutes so um the Lisp
community in Emacs community have done a
lot of this sort of you'll have this
this server running and I interact with
it with various Emacs or things like
people have done this sort of thing in
other communities before with much less
sexiness granted but is there any
communication back and forth or is there
any is there any interaction between the
US and the Lisp community or the ideas
passing back and forth yeah I'm not
aware of it except to know that some
Emacs user right or emacs users in
general have used it so they've really
the they're not they don't use any of
our ipython notebook javascript front
end they've reimplemented all of that
there's a lisp or skiing or whatever
emacs uses web sockets implementation
that they use to speak ICCP to our web
server so so there are crazy people out
there but i don't know that i don't know
the community is and we should say this
this is called Emacs I Pike the netbook
yes I'm if you want to go and search for
I pulled it up here and and there's a
link to it in the in the talk yeah
there's lots of crazy people out there
okay let's give Thompson and Paula Ron
applause oh I have stickers we have
stickers they have stickers and then
there's a break for food you want that
way that'd be great or come up here and
shower them with accolades